[Music]
I don't see any strawberries I know I
saw them well maybe they ran away
because they were intimidated by this
this isn't babies learning everything
this is when it imprints hmm
you know careful all of a sudden the
baby thinks that it's refrigerators its
father what's not what happened to you
I'll tell you what happened to me I'll
tell you what happened to me I didn't
see my father for the first two years of
his life of his life can't really
explain what I'm feeling but I like it
[Music]
I'm good you guys good could that have
been a more dance appropriate sort of
I'm feeling that it's it's very full so
I don't think she's been released at all
you're definitely feeling that the baby
should grab on to that I think you will
that hard
yeah it's getting repetitive I think we
got it look I can't legally watch this
unfold it comes dangerously close to
prostitution I want I contact do you
understand how rare that is in nature
I'm not some farm animal
Hey he had a curiosity do you have any
other characters oh I'm working on
Scranton strangler oh I'm working on a
new one it's granny strangler Oh working
on the Scranton strangler I'm working
I'm working on a new one strand
strangler Kelly is even worse than Daryl
if you'd have told me this morning that
today I'd be creating a monster capable
of my own destruction
I thought you were referring to the bull
or trying to reanimate okay you know
what Jim I am taking you off this
account for unrelated read don't you
smirk at me okay okay you know what Jim
get your tongue in your face okay you
know what Jim I am taking you off his
account for unrelated reasons he was
really close to you just let him flirt
with her people meet each other all
sorts of wait who are we to stand in the
way
Pam you know he's not gonna get anywhere
and you know he's gonna blow our sale
who cares it's not that huge a sale the
Schwab yeah you know he's not gonna get
anywhere and you know he's gonna blow
our sale who cares it's not that you
just sale this wrong guy he does this
here is a radon test kit okay I'll be
putting them everywhere and please don't
throw these out this is a radon test kit
please don't throw these out wait for it
Wow and that's a front wedgie think you
have to admit you flipped out a little
bit I think you should stop talking now
I just wouldn't she's still awesome are
you sitting on your knowing a ton I
[Laughter]
think that I'm just a little sore still
yeah but you're going on huh it's not
like I'm meeting anyone on chatroulette
I was so southern did you hear it oh my
goodness it's not like I'm making anyone
on chatroulette
I do declare Rhett why don't you care
the same voice okay okay you know what I
want you to get tired walking around all
this
who is it who is it Michael you say hi
hi what's your blood type O Negative
Universal donor universal donor you have
to have sex with a woman hmm
ten sex with a man and then just compare
the two mmm
preferably bit in the same night would
you consider nope taking that boy for me
[Laughter]
well you just have to sleep with a woman
I can do that it's like with man then
just compare I'm gonna think about both
mmm
what are you free sorry I saw you at the
wedding
oh yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello that's great imma tell him you
guys sexually harassed my sister
sexually and judge is gonna believe that
[Laughter]
fine I'll just tell me you guys sexually
harassed my no secret crying doesn't
even open the tissue box no secret
crying Wow
so we're gonna go with the most logical
thing is that he matured overnight wait
for it hold on you want because I am a
male Santa and that is something that
Phyllis cannot do oh really comfortable
tell me what you want little boy what
did you think was going to happen I
didn't know no one's ever let me sit on
their lap before hurry up just say some
can you give me some choices oh my god
copper squat what would you like for
Christmas a little Kevin I don't know I
didn't know you were gonna ask me that
well what did you think was going to
happen here
[Laughter]
you